mais qui sont les meilleurs prospects
américains de l'équipe
U17 qui a remporté le Championnat du
Monde ce mois de juillet en Espagne
avait plusieurs phénomènes plusieurs
possibles futurs stars des drames
2024-2025 même 2026 on vous les présente
on va essayer de les classer bienvenue
c'est envergure
[Musique]
on a donc du pain sur la planche pour
parler de cette équipe américaine
d'abord ils l'ont vu en live en Espagne
depuis les tribunes les inséparables
Walter White Jesse Pinkman Manu Alan
comment allez-vous
qui est le scientifique qui est le
junkie
ou précisera pas
et lui connaissait déjà la plupart des
joueurs de l'équipe US pour les avoir vu
en High School il a regardé le CDM
U17 depuis sa chaise longue ou son
canapé ou sa chaise de bureau premier
podcast en tant que membre officiel
d'envergure je crois pour toi Thomas azk
pour les intimes salut Thomas exactement
depuis le lit même j'ai envie de dire
donc salut à tous et moi on a regardé
donc heureux d'être là pour pour ce
premier podcast avec la maison c'est un
plaisir donc vous allez vous compléter
puisque puisque ta toi tu regardes pas
mal d'événements pré NCA donc ça permet
de voir les joueurs dans un rôle
différent de ce qu'ils ont généralement
en FIBA Thomas quand même vu que c'est
ton premier podcast on précise que tu es
breton encore un breton de plus dans
l'équipe envergure et alors on sait ce
qui nous suivent le savent Allan
supporter de Nantes Manu de Rennes
est-ce que toi tu peux trancher en tant
que Breton ou pas et habitants de Rennes
je suis le plus grand supporter de
l'Olympique de Marseille de France donc
je vais pas pouvoir trancher ce débat
bon un débat intrans chez en plus il me
semble que Mathias qui nous a rejoint
aussi supporter de l'OL donc ça devient
n'importe quoi
au niveau football
full de prospect donc dans cette équipe
USA U17 on s'y jette vous avez déjà un
article récap sur notre site
envergure.co c'est Manu qu'il a fait
allez le checker mais vous inquiétez pas
on va vous les représenter au fur et à
mesure ça va être tranquille
je vous ai demandé de les classer
messieurs les les prospects mais avant
de de vous demander vos classement on va
quand même redire l'importance de ces
rosters Coupe du Monde
USA généralement il y a énormément de
draftés on prend l'exemple de 2018
on a on a deux joueurs qui sont encore à
la fac Harmon et roche Roméo Winx qui
galère avec Memphis et sinon on a 9
draftés dont
1 2 3 4 5 dans le top 10 Evan mobile
2016 c'était un peu moins bien mais on
avait quand même du Emmanuel quickly
Collins Sexton Gary Trent Troy Brown
Kevin Knox Gigi
Wendel Carter donc
voilà c'était c'était pas si mal le les
ce qu'on disparu du roadster 2016 petit
quiz petit est-ce que vous savez où joue
Jordan Brown
l'intérieur de cette équipe 2016 il y a
encore la fac
il a fait durer on va dire ça comme ça
[Rires]
il joue à Louisiana
ok chez les Red jings
rien à voir avec les Noirs
puisque ça veut dire les Cadiens les
Cadiens c'est un groupe ethnique de
Louisiane voilà j'ai fait je me suis
passionné pour cette recherche il
descendent des Acadiens et c'est donc
des francophones qui ont été expulsés du
Canada et c'est pour ça qu'il y a plein
de français en Louisiane entre autres
voilà donc les régimes cajun de
Louisiana pour Jordan Brown Austin Wiley
vous savez où il joue
et maintenant il joue en Europe
et il y en a un qui a un peu disparu je
crois qu'il joue à grand blindstate mais
s'appelle Carter arrêt Gordon
à 5 jours absolument absolument bon
voilà pour pour le petit historique tout
ça pour dire que en règle générale les
rosters alors les rosters pour le FIBA
américain c'est à dire les championnats
continentaux donc U16 U18 sont peut-être
moins représentatifs moins qualitatif
quand on regarde down the road mais les
roster U17 U19 donc qui sont des
Championnats du Monde généralement il y
a quand même des gros noms et c'était le
cas on pense en tout cas que c'était le
cas encore une fois pour cette édition
2022 alors alors le classement
qui est-ce que vous avez tout en haut
c'est moi qui ferais les présentations
des joueurs qu'on vous mettrai d'accord
sur le classement et puis après on verra
qu'elle quel développement on peut
espérer pour pour ces prospects qui ont
donc entre 15 et 17 ans qui qui est tout
en haut de ton classement Thomas qui est
dans le premier groupe en tout cas il y
a le groupe des prospects des gros
prospects
alors dans mon premier groupe j'ai
monsieur DJ Wagner
Jackson et j'ai monsieur cooperfly
également j'ai trois trois joueurs ok tu
n'as pas quoi pit
non je n'ai pas quoi il est dans mon
deuxième ok Alan je sais pas si tu as
fonctionné par groupe ou pas bien sûr
j'ai j'ai coupé Flac tout seul OK et
Manu
si tu devais faire des
groupes j'ai cooperfly et chon Stewart
ok bon on n'a pas les mêmes noms à
droite à gauche alors je pense que pour
Wagner ça s'explique parce que il était
beaucoup plus performant en High School
qu'il ne l'a été lors de ce championnat
du monde
le nom le nom qui revient chez vous
trois c'est c'est cooperfly donc bah
Cooper flag c'est parti
qui est-il 21 décembre 2006 donc il a
encore 15 ans donc 21 décembre 2006 moi
je préparais mon brevet des collèges
déjà quand même un coup de vieux il sera
éligible théoriquement donc en 2026 mais
avec son âge il pourrait l'être dès 2025
ça va dépendre un peu de son parcours
lycéen
2 m 01 il jouait allez jouer intérieur
mais jouer 4 5 quoi il vient du main
sa mère a fait 4 ans de basket dans
l'équipe de la fac
il sera l'année prochaine à la monde
Verde Academy la fameuse et quand même
ces stats donc il était première année
lycéen donc c'est à dire première de on
est d'accord c'est quatre années
théoriquement le lycée Thomas
première année les moyennes 21 points
dit rebonds s'y passe 4 interceptions
quatre contre
donc compte des joueurs qu'on
potentiellement trois ans de plus que
lui et amphiba il a fait pareil il
jouait 19 minutes par match et à 9
points 10 rebonds deux passes décisive
de virgule 4 interceptions 2,9 contre le
seul
je dirais là où le bas blesse c'est au
pourcentage puisqu'il a tiré seulement
41% à deux points à trois points il a
appris que 7 3 points 3 sur 7 pas si mal
8 sur 11 au lancer franc sur la
compétition entière un des meilleurs
plasminer c'est pas le meilleur mais un
des meilleurs plus mainus moyen de de ce
Team USA on note au niveau de la famille
donc sa mère elle jouait à main may
University et il a un jumeau aussi
cooperfly
qui n'était pas dans l'équipe mais il a
un jumeau donc j'adore les jumeaux
puisque ça nous permet quand même de
suivre l'évolution parallèle on a les on
a les Murray on a
on a les on a d'autres jumeaux les
Thompson merci pour la pour la
son frère
donc donc c'est intéressant à suivre les
différentes progressions des des jumeaux
on va avoir pas mal de jumeaux
théoriquement NBA Cooper flag Alan toi
tu dis que tu l'avais tout seul alors
vas-y explique-moi pourquoi quelles sont
ces qualités de basket
c'est pas que j'aime pas les autres
franchement des dans mon deuxième tir il
y a des joueurs que je pense qui sont
déjà labellisables comme le tribuk mais
c'est juste que couper flag pour en fait
c'est je crois que c'est le meilleur
joueur que j'ai vu en vrai le meilleur
prospect que j'ai dû voir en vrai de ça
de porter un je veux dire
[Musique]
il est grand il est long il a un des
meilleurs timings de timing de contre
que j'ai vu de protection de cercle à
son âge donc tu as dit de décembre 2006
il peut contrer des deux mains il peut
contrer à une main à une main ou à
demain et puis moi j'achète le tir parce
que en fait on a moi j'ai pu le voir
contre l'Egypte tu crois et en fait
Égypte je suis resté un carton mais je
suis resté une heure avant pour le voir
juste shooter à échauffement parce que
bon l'opposition égyptienne n'était pas
n'était pas incroyable et en fait il
prenait beaucoup de tirs extérieurs et
moi je le projette comme un futur
stretch 4 5 qui peu importe protéger le
cercle qui peut passer
qu'à des excellentes stocks donc style
interception donc un puit défensif
ultra développé et il va encore grandir
parce que avec Manu on a vu le papa et
croyez moi le papa
est une bonne génétique
bah oui parce que il a 15 ans donc ça
serait pas étonnant qui finissent à deux
sets de 8 quoi
Manu est-ce que tu as des tu as noté des
choses toi en
je dirais en
terrain ou plutôt sur le côté attitude
quelqu'un qui regarde vachement ça
est-ce que tu as été aussi convaincu par
ça par sur les attitudes de cooperfly
ouais très bonne latitude que ce soit
sur le banc ou sur le terrain toujours
en train d'encourager ou comme pas mal
de gens sur le banc américain mais
toujours en train d'encourager
d'applaudir de sur le terrain de faire
le dolphe vraiment il a l'air en tout
cas d'être un bon gars ouais il y a pas
eu de trucs négatifs en tout cas de sur
le banc ou sur le terrain toi si tu le
mets dans ton dans ton premier groupe
est-ce que tu as d'autres qualités à
ajouter à celle que
qui a déjà décrit Alan
non non le peut-être latéralité jusqu'à
il y a vraiment des trucs sur notamment
sur l'aide défensive ou des fois il est
vraiment loin parce qu'il défend sur sur
des quatre trois enfin de des gens de sa
taille et du coup il a sur un pas il
arrive tout de suite il est au Cercle
quasiment en un pas et ça c'est pas de
la latéralité défense un contrat c'est
de la latéralité vraiment protection de
cercle c'est impressionnant avoir en
vrai où il y a l'âne parler de timing
mais il y a aussi cette vitesse sur les
petits espaces
et
savoir ce projeter effectivement que ce
soit latéralement ou en arrière etc pour
aller pour aller protéger le cercle
Thomas est-ce que tu as d'autres choses
à ajouter sur le profil de cooperflack
que tu as aussi mis du coup dans ton ton
premier ton premier tiers non
complètement d'accord avec ce qui a été
dit défensivement je pense qu'il a
impressionné tout le monde même ce soir
même vocalement j'ai envie de dire
toujours il était là à placer ses
coéquipiers il faisait les aides quand
il fallait ils faisaient les bonnes
rotations il avait il avait les yeux
partout donc il était vraiment assez
incroyable défensivement il a vraiment
il a vraiment sorti du lot de ce côté là
du terrain et même offensivement il y a
pas mal de flash le shoot a l'air pas
mal en place ça part haut en plus avec
ses immenses bras c'est vraiment assez
impressionnant même des petits flashs de
London je me souviens d'un petit dribble
dans le dos avec un petit tiramis
distance qui finit qui finit pas au fond
mais ça va ça m'avait marqué ce petit
tir donc non je trouve qu'il est
ultra impressionnant défensivement il
est encore quatre ans pour spolier
offensivement que ce soit dans son chou
dans son Haendel dans son jeu de passe
qui est déjà intéressant donc il y a toi
construire facilement il y a tout ajouté
encore il y a pas mal de choses à
continuer tout simplement mais
défensivement il est déjà il est déjà
élite j'ai envie de dire au rebond il
est incroyable et donc on va continuer à
polir son jeu offensif et dans 4 ans ça
peut devenir ça peut devenir incroyable
au monde donc ouais il est forcément
dans le tir 1 et c'est même le premier
du tir 1 j'ai envie de dire
tu as raison de souligner un quand même
rebond alors même si voilà il dominait
par sa parce que il plus athlétique etc
mais un an un an un an et demi de moins
que la majorité de ses adversaires et
prenait donc bah 20 rebonds si on fait
des stats sur 40 minutes 20 rebonds par
match quoi
2m 01 donc ça laisse songeur sur le
timing
donc effectivement à mon Verdez
Thomas et ce qui va pouvoir s'exprimer
un peu avec le ballon est-ce qu'il y a
des gros on imagine qu'il y a des gros
porteurs de balles avec lui quand même
il y a eu pas mal de recrutement un
monde VRD mais il y a eu pas mal de tous
les gros joueurs sont partis quasiment
il y a d'Harry White qui est parti
Skype
donc un gros renouveau il va y avoir
censé être la star de l'équipe mais
c'est pas vraiment un Bollène l'heure ça
c'est également plus des porteurs sur
sur les postes il y a vraiment tout à
reconstruire dans dans cette équipe de
monde VRD il y a peu à peu près
d'accord ah ouais
[Musique]
il a joué quand même plus de 20 minutes
par match donc il n'était pas là pour
faire de la figuration pour avoir un
jeune pour former
9,6 points 4 bons 1,6 passes décisives
une interception à contre par match il
jouait plutôt à poste 3 si je devais
donner un poste 3 même si ça c'était
très polyvalent on va dire cette équipe
US 54% à deux points seulement 5 3
points tentés 1 sur 5 10 sur 22 au
lancer France c'est pas bien
son père alors toutes ces tous les
hommes de sa famille sont plutôt dans le
foot
foutus son père a fait du foot en
College c'est trois frères font du foot
en College et ces deux sœurs par contre
sont côté basket il vient de l'Arizona
kwapit et d'ailleurs il est en School en
Arizona d'ailleurs je sais pas si c'est
un gros High School là où il est
à la tête je te pose une colle
non mais vu qu'il est à sa première
année High School je pense qu'il va pas
finir sa carrière school là je pense
[Musique]
dans la classe de recrutement 2025 il
est devant cooperfly quand même selon
tout Fortis seven tout forcément et
derrière cambouseur qui est aussi un
gros talent mais pour tout ça pour dire
je parlais de sa famille tout ça pour
dire qu'elle a un pedigree athlétique
puisqu'ils ont tous des bourses quand
même
les trois les quatre frères les deux
soeurs
de mémoire en drus Pitt c'est un line
meno c'est une famille de sportifs
quelles sont les qualités basket que tu
as vu
moi j'ai apprécié le
physique on vous le disait le pays mais
il est déjà quasiment prêt en jouant une
billet dès demain uniquement par le
physique c'est un joueur qui monte assez
vite au cercle très bon dans le second
dans le second show aussi on l'a très
bien vu là dessus notamment sur le
rebond où il quasiment il a pas fini son
premier saut qu'il est déjà remonté en
l'air c'est assez impressionnant tiens
très très bien le contact aussi j'ai
bien aimé le shoot malgré le
pourcentage assez horrible à 3 points
mais en fait ce qui me plaît dans un
joueur c'est étage là c'est qui tente
plus qu'une le met c'est ça la réussite
viendra après pour pour moi donc au
moins je l'ai vu tenter que ce soit à
trois points et à mi distance donc ça
c'est assez cool de voir un joueur comme
ça et c'était pas forcément son rôle
dans l'équipe parce qu'il y avait des
gros shooters notamment on en parlera
peut-être après David Castillo qui était
lui était vraiment le footer à titre de
l'équipe
mais c'est intéressant quand même de le
voir et j'ai bien aimé aussi ça défense
notamment sur le 1 contre 1 ou c'est un
jour très intéressant sur la défense
dans le périmètre très bonne lettre
enfin un très bonnes la télé pour un
pour un gamin de 15 ans donc un peu plus
dans on va c'est pas le bon terme mais
dans en difficulté sur la défense
d'équipe mais autrement sur le un
contrat en fait de par sa latéralité et
son
ultra large de de corps en fait il
pouvait défendre sur n'importe qui et
personne pouvait forcément le passer
parce que la combinaison des deux
faisait qu'il avait toujours l'avantage
que ce soit sur des petits ou sur des
grands
physique impressionnant honnêtement pour
un gamin de 15 ans c'est fou parce
qu'autant couper flag on voit quand même
qu'il est jeune même si il est déjà
costaud etc malgré les cheveux on voit
qu'il a un visage des bébés
comme tu dis s'il a 18 ans moi je suis
pas choqué tu vois vraiment
corporellement
effectivement je suis pas choqué Thomas
est-ce que tu as des choses à ajouter
sur le jeu de quoi pits ouais moi je
l'ai trouvé également intéressant
défensivement peut-être plus que Manu
dans dans la défense collective je
trouve qu'ils aient des rotations plutôt
pas mal il a provoqué quelques passages
en force au moins deux de mémoire après
offensivement j'attends j'attends
d'avoir plus simplement ça reste un
joueur très jeune qui domine
principalement physiquement c'est un
joueur qui qui brûlit pas mal dans la
peinture au cercle avec son physique
impressionnant c'est un Miss match
permanent pour l'instant donc j'attends
tout simplement de voir son son
développement offensif sur sur plusieurs
années comme Manu également j'aime
plutôt bien son tir sa mécanique au
lancer franc et plutôt bonne je trouve
donc j'ai nuance un peu son 45% lancer
sur survivant je trouve pas trop plutôt
pas mal la bile au lancer je trouve
qu'il est assez fluide donc à voir et au
niveau du chou pareil ça va être ça va
être à développer mais reste assez
fluide donc développer le shoot le jeu
offensive développer son shoot
développer son jeu de passe également
mais les bases défensives sont vraiment
bonnes donc genre vraiment intéressant
genre très physique il va continuer de
grandir donc vraiment intéressant sur le
poste de carte il me fait un peu penser
à un physiquement le banquiero donc s'il
développe c'est schizophrénie Alan sur
le sur tout for seven il la comparaison
est tout simplement en simplicité Kate
koenigam pourquoi kit
est-ce que tu as des mémoires de keid au
même âge est-ce que parce que parce
qu'il fait à peu près sa taille et il a
son gabarit aussi c'est pour ça ouais le
jeune Kate c'était un
c'était je vois ce qu'il veut dire parce
que Kate est très jeune donc avant qu'il
aille à Mondevert donc quand il était
encore au Texas il jouait poste 4
post-up proche du poignet mais c'est
qu'en fait il a développé ce jeu de
passe pour devenir un bowlingler
principal ce que je vois pas encore chez
cohabit après moi je l'ai vu que deux
fois en live
parce que
en même temps avec avec Manu mais moi ce
que je trouve c'est qui c'est un très
fort joueur proche du panier il est très
bon sur second saut il prend beaucoup de
regroupons offensif de dos en fait il a
il a le il a pas le dos d'un humain d'un
jeune de son âge il a un dos et
musculature hyper développé mais on sent
qu'il va quand même un peu grandir parce
que
comme tu l'as dit le pedure familial les
frères sont les frères jouent énormément
donc des gens monstrueusement grands
donc en fait donc en grandir mais je
vois un peu ça oui c'est à dire être
très fort au post-up après voilà Kate
dans sa deuxième troisième quatrième
année lycée à apporter
le poulet puis il l'a apporté plus tard
mais il a apporté surtout la création de
ballon on verra si on donne la balle à
cohabite là c'est un contexte qu'on lui
donnait pas la balle dans les mains de
Wagner de ronoland de Jérémy fears donc
on verra pour pourquoi pas avoir je peux
pas dire non je peux pas dire oui ça
c'est sûr sur l'axe de progression en
tout cas c'est ça si on veut en faire un
top prospect faut qu'il ait la le ballon
dans les mois à court terme
pour j'avais pas posé la question pour
pour couper flag Manu toi tu vois tu
vois quel
quel développement a apporté à son jeu
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il faut c'est
quoi le développement idéal quel vers
quel genre de joueur on va le modeler
j'hésite entre encore en sur un selon sa
taille finale c'est sur un stretch five
ou strange fort je vois bien un mec qui
va être à terme capable de la fois
protéger le cercle mais aussi de pouvoir
tirer défendre sur du 3 4 5 parce que
c'est pas un peu gâché vu le le QI du
monsieur de pas le de pas lui faire
prendre plus de décision enfin
il pourrait apprendre en a vu des choses
assez intéressantes notamment sur des
sur des transitions ou des fois ils
prenaient le rebond il partait tout seul
en costoucost mais je suis pas j'ai
encore du mal à identifier le handle
honnêtement à voir ce qui pourrait bien
je l'ai vu là l'autre fois qu'on sur le
contre les frangins boosers et on le
voit totalement différent en fait
beaucoup moins la balle en main beaucoup
plus en difficulté physiquement donc je
vois le truc en fait enfin je vois ce
que tu veux dire mais j'ai du mal à le
projeter avec énormément la balle en
main moi aujourd'hui on verra dans ne
serait-ce que dans deux ans mais
notamment le passage à monde ouvert qui
va penser un peu son jeu
s'il va être avec des joueurs totalement
différents en termes de niveau qu'il a
dans le Main no offens mais
il va tomber contre des meilleurs
joueurs aussi donc avoir comment ils
vont le est-ce qu'il sera déjà esquisse
ratitulaire ça c'est pas sûr et ce que
voilà faut avoir
une C qui nous a dit c'est le meilleur
joueur de l'histoire du monde
ouais mais après il doit être le seul en
fait donc compliqué mais sa mère quoi
[Rires]
on passe à donc l'autre qui est deux
fois dans votre deuxième tiers
c'est l'ami DJ Wagner DJ pour dajwan
Wagner junior puisque c'est le fils de
l'ancien drafté par Cleveland joueur NBA
sixième pic de la draft 2022 2022 2002
quand même
et son alors attention pedigree aussi
petit-fils de 1000 Wagner
qui était pro basketteur pro passer par
Louisville à la fac et qui travaille
encore à Louisville à la fac
Louisville il est responsable du player
développement donc c'est pas rien et
Louisville est en cours pour recruter
d'adjointe Wagner
on a bien lu c'est qui le coach de Louis
c'est le nouveau coach c'est Kenny Payne
qui était l'assistant de Cali Paris
avant qui était au Nyx mais il a envoyé
ses deux assistants principaux donc
Nolan Smith c'est un joueur de Duke et
d'animaling
qui sont ces deux assistants et qui
était là trois fois pour avoir
tous les matchs ça recrute fort
en face il y a Kentucky aussi qui est
venu
qui essaie de le recruter donc il est en
dans le New Jersey en High School Camden
Camden High School Camden high
qui a il a remporté le titre de l'État
voilà il recrut numéro 1 2023 selon le
Composit tranquille de tout forcément
un poste 1 2 1m90 il était un peu allez
un peu en dedans au niveau de l'adresse
en tout cas 20 minutes par match il a
ajouté seulement à 48% à deux points et
qu'à 4 sur 21 3 points
7 sur 8 au lancer donc au final c'est
9.3 rebonds trois à six deux styles de
moyenne pour DJ Wagner Thomas quelles
sont les qualités du monsieur
alors DJ Wagner c'est un meneur assez
complet il s'est un peu il s'est un peu
déjà tout faire en fait c'est on l'a vu
au FIBA U17 donc il a pas été il a pas
été à droite réclamant c'était la même
chose ensuite il y a maintenant moins
d'une semaine au petit j'aime alors
qu'il avait été vraiment rayonnant sur
les trois premières sessions de l'ewei
oui on est à 50% au tir sur les trois
sessions c'est là qui était vraiment
était vraiment au top de sa forme c'est
pour ça que ça m'a un peu surpris son il
en a eu un vrai coup de moins bien sur
les deux dernières divent mais c'est un
genre vraiment que je trouve
personnellement très très fort
défensivement les déjà donc plus qu'en
place c'est un joueur qui a une bonne
taille 1m90 prend meneur c'est pas mal
qui est déjà assez solide qui a les
mains actifs qui est intelligent qui se
donne vraiment beaucoup sur les sur les
replis défensifs les souvent là pour
pour aller venir gêner offensivement
c'est un joueur c'est un joueur plutôt
assez vif assez rapide même s'il est un
peu en temps pour attaquer le cercle au
fibu 17 je trouve mais habituellement
surtout à l'ewibier il avait une belle
facilité d'accès au cercle en under plus
que correct des belles qualités
athlétiques un sens de la passe
également plus que bon je dirais avril
plus bon c'est pas encore un élite
passeur je pense que son step up pour
devenir un vrai vrai joueur élite
devenir par la page je pense sinon c'est
un score intéressant comme je l'ai dit
les capotes d'aller au cercle il est
capable de créer son pull-up à midi
distance à trois points il avait des
bons pourcentages à louer Biel comme je
l'ai dit que ce soit mi distance à trois
points il était ouais il était à 50 % au
tir il était à 35 40 %, 3 points 80 %
lancer donc il était vraiment au dessus
de laver au dessus de la concurrence
j'ai envie de dire il y avait les
prospects 2023 il y avait DJ Wagner qui
dominait un peu tout le monde il était
dans une bonne équipe également donc
pour moi c'est vraiment l'un des si ce
n'est le top prospect de cette équipe
futur très très bon meneur qui s'est
déjà un peu tout faire et qui doit en
plus se spécialiser encore plus je pense
dans dans Le Play making pour pour
pouvoir rester sur ce poste 1 au lieu
d'être un
undersize tout un petit peu qui n'est
peut-être pas un élite un élite square
je pense que ça doit plus être un élite
passeur
de très bons scorer très bon défenseur
sur le poste 1 qui a un petit deux qui
s'est un peu tout faire
à l'année est-ce que tu es d'accord sur
les axes de développement pour pour
Wagner
et en même temps souvent on se disait ça
quand on était dans le dans les tribunes
en fait il fait pas un très bon tournoi
mais tu sens que tu sens qu'il est que
c'est le mais c'était le meilleur garde
en fait de timio c'est que dans la fine
dans les changements de rythme dans la
main l'intensité qui peut mettre sur sur
petit espace la finition cercle pas
incroyable mais ça allait la plus forcer
sur du mid range pull up compliqué et du
poulet pas trop bon c'est super forcé
mais qui continue à aller autant au
cercle et qu'il améliore sa vision du
jeu sur pick and roll parce que c'est ce
qui en fera un primeur
en NBA pourquoi je l'ai pas tire un
c'est parce qu'il est pour moi il est
fini physiquement un peu et ça se voit
qu'il est il grandira pas encore
énormément il est pas non plus très long
donc
c'est pour ça mais en tant que porteur
de balles il est il a tous il développe
la vision sur pick-kendroll et sur
driving kick pour pour accélérer la
danse sur la vivacité premier pas c'est
vraiment on est sur de l'élite ou sur un
bon joueur
pas sur un vrai bon joueur qui est en
plus un croyable
faisaient leur quantité leurs
échauffements ils mettaient les quatre
gardes en même temps pour faire des des
du travail pendant 10-15 minutes juste
sur le handle en terme de motricité tu
penses tu aurais adoré voir ça et si
plein d'exos différents motricité avec
des petits ballons des balles et des
choses comme ça et les autres étaient
incroyables notamment bougifland mais
lui il est il a vraiment un deuil qui
lui permet d'aller là où il veut quand
il veut
Manu pourquoi toi tu l'as pas dans ton
dans ton top dans tes prospects du
premier groupe qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui te fait douter chez Wagner
un peu tout j'ai pas aimé le shoot j'ai
pas aimé le puissance sur premier pas
moi je trouve qu'il a pas eu de réussite
à passer ses défenseurs beaucoup de
finitions très difficiles où ils fonce
dans le défenseur il a pas réussi à tes
accès pour pour marquer
c'est offensivement j'ai vraiment pas
accroché du tout en fait sur quoi qu'il
fasse excepté le handle et des fois la
le changement de vitesse reste
impressionnant mais je en fait c'est
ça c'est des cales enfin des c'est des
défauts qu'on peut retrouver sur les
joueurs américains face à des joueurs
européens c'est un jeu européen des
règles européennes ça se trouve en
Kentucky Louisville enfin une scie
l'année prochaine il va totalement être
différent parce que le spacing ça a
complètement différent les règles seront
aussi différentes mais là notamment sur
les
sur entre guillemets les forces équipes
qu'il a vu à la fin donc Australie
Serbie Espagne
là finalement il a été très peu en vue
en attaque excepté sur la sur la
Lituanie ou là il a été bon il a 12
points montre-moi les autres matchs il a
5 et 6 points donc c'est il a aucune
pour moi j'ai enfin moi je l'ai pas vu
avoir un impact offensif sur lequel je
m'attendais parce que je m'attends je
connaissais de nom évidemment top top 5
joueurs lycéen voilà donc je m'attendais
à quelque chose d'un peu plus
impressionnant en fait offensivement par
contre défensivement il m'a impressionné
de oufs le long bras la télé incroyable
peu défendre sur du 1 2 il là dessus
ultra énergique imotor voilà toujours
toujours dans l'effort mais
offensivement j'ai été très très déçu
ok alors à voir si c'est l'histoire
d'une d'une compète ou
effectivement s'il y a des inquiétudes
qui pourraient se matérialiser pour la
suite
alors ensuite vous aviez tous des noms
un petit peu différents dans votre dans
votre premier tiers
on avait on avait qui chez Thomas on en
a oublié ou pas chez moi
on parle de Yann Jackson donc lui pour
le coup d'ailleurs c'était le cas de
Wagner aussi je l'ai pas dit mais il est
2005 donc ça c'est l'âge normal pour
participer à ce U17 contrairement à
quoi pit et Cooper flag Yann Jackson
qui vient du Bronx cardinal high scho
qui a été médaillé l'année dernière au
U16 médaillée d'or U16 américain il a
pas mal grandi depuis à l'époque il
m'avait pas marqué moi qui avait fait
l'article sur sur le site il m'avait pas
énormément marqué mais il a j'ai
l'impression qu'il a grandi en tout cas
il a annoncé à 2 m à l'époque il était
pas du tout
17 ans donc numéro 3 des recrues 2024
selon ispienne numéro 2 même selon le
composite ranking et sur ce FIBA U17 17
minutes
12.59% à 2 points 9 sur 20 de loin mais
il n'a tiré de loin que dans les petits
matchs donc c'est à relativiser ces 9
sur 20 de loin dans les petits matchs
entre guillemets face au vraiment aux
petites équipes en poule quand quand le
au lieu de gagner de 15 points les USA
gagnaient de 40 ou 50 points et donc au
final en moyenne ça fait 4 points 6
rebonds 1,7 passe décisive 1,4
interceptions Thomas parle-moi de Yann
Jackson pourquoi tu
personnellement j'aime beaucoup donc
comme tu l'as dit c'est un espèce de
poste 2 assez grand qui approche des
deux mètres maintenant et je trouve
vraiment qu'il a qu'il a toutes les
qualités toutes les capacités tout le
corps pour devenir un très très bon
arrière premièrement c'est un vrai bon
athlète un joueur qu'un bon premier pas
un genre de bonne taille un joueur
athlétique qui crée assez facilement son
accès aux cercle c'est un genre qui a
également un vrai bond de lit il danse
vraiment avec la balle il est capable de
changement de rythme de changement de
direction vraiment très très
spectaculaire donc il a un accès au
cercle de par ses qualités techniques et
de par ses qualités athlétiques très
facile il finit plutôt bien donc c'est
intéressant même si il a pris très très
peu de lancer
U17 nous sommes m'avait un peu surpris
par rapport à ce que j'avais vu en High
School c'est également un joueur qui a
beaucoup progressé sur son shoot à trois
points il a bien shooté sur U17 il a
plutôt bien shooté sur sa fin High
School c'est un joueur qui est une
mécanique vraiment très pure je le
trouve vraiment très à l'aise sur son
shoot donc en cas de chaîne shoot il y a
vraiment aucun problème ça s'affiloche
en cas de problème c'est également un
joueur qui a des qualités passent plutôt
intéressantes il commence petit à petit
à débloquer des qualités de playmaking
il joue plutôt pas mal Ball en main en
High School c'est pas un joueur qui a
toutes les possessions non plus peine
attaquer le biocentrique mais il a pas
mal de ballons ça reste le meilleur
joueur de son équipe donc il fait pas
mal joué les partenaires il commence à
débloquer de ça de plus en plus c'est
également un joueur intéressant
défensivement de par sa longueur de par
son énergie c'est un genre qui met
beaucoup de un seul quand il joue son en
défense on attaque beaucoup de trashto
également et au global donc c'est un
joueur qui a comme je dis toutes les
qualités pendant 2 pour devenir un gros
arrière il manque à continuer de
développer je pense que le point qui
doit continuer de développer c'est son
jeu de poulables de venir le meilleur
possible sur flop pour être ce crack
offensif de satuer j'ai envie de dire le
genre qui poula pas trop enfin le joueur
qui pour l'a pas mis distance pour
parfaire ça sa panoplie offensive et là
déjà une vraie panoplie de scoring le
passing c'est déjà pas mal la défense
est intéressante il a toutes les
qualités athlétiques toutes les qualités
taille les mensurations pour donc pour
moi ça peut vraiment être un très très
gros arrière de la classe 2024
très bien à l'année Manu est-ce que vous
avez quelque chose à ajouter sur Yann
Jackson
[Musique]
moi je suis pour moi chaud sur le
potentiel c'est un fort joueur mais pour
moi il est il a beaucoup moins de
potentiel que d'autres joueurs de timio
c'est pour ça qu'il a excellent aussi
parce qu'il est prêt quoi
potentiellement plus un fluend dire en
NBA je pense
3 il peut développer mais la plupart de
ces trois points c'est du 4e shoot
la qualité de passe que voit Thomas elle
est là mais je lui donne pas la balle en
NBA je pense donc pour moi ça sera un
très très fort joueur de complément
peut-être pas une star
on passe à la suite parce qu'on traîne
Manute avec qui dans ton Stewart toi
c'est ça que tu m'as dit
2005 aussi 2 mètres 0,3
qui a lui très bien shooté 7 sur 18 à 3
points
mais il a pris que 9 de points 4 sur 9
ah non pardon je confond ça c'est Boogie
7 points cette rebond de moyenne pour
chaîne Stewart en 18 minutes 46% de
poids aucun 3 points tenté on sur 15 au
lancer franc
une interception un compte de moyenne du
comics déjà l'an prochain numéro 8 du
composite pour l'instant il est à
windermir High School c'est près de
Orlando en Floride qu'est-ce que tu vois
chez lui Manu
un mec qui ultra de tanquer c'est
vraiment physiquement il est quasi il
est il est terminé ce qui est un square
de niveau pour l'instant promis distance
et près du cercle et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il a comme il a pas
mis trois points on fait pas tenter et
c'est que ça mécanique est totalement
différente plus il s'éloigne mieux elle
est donc c'est ça c'est à voir dans le
futur c'est quoi il est mi distance en
fait il termine pas son geste il tire
quasiment qu'avec son poignet alors que
quand il prenait des longs deux en fait
il lâche complètement son bras et la
fluidité la mécanique était vraiment
plus intéressante mais il n'était pas
forcément dedans donc ça va être à
observer ça sur sur les prochaines
saisons mais offensivement c'est un gars
qui est capable de se créer son
screen l'espace du job step terminé au
Cercle d'enchaîner rapidement de voilà
c'est moi j'ai énormément aimé le seul
hit que j'ai c'est ce que j'ai compris
c'est que c'est beaucoup de main gauche
pour l'instant très peu de ma main
droite même si ce qui va grandir encore
parce que là tu me décris un joueur qui
va quand même je pense pas sur du 4 5 et
de mettre 0,3 c'est pas très grand
non je pense pas qu'il va faire ou
peut-être un ou deux centimètres parce
qu'il doit encore avoir un an de je sais
plus s'il a un an encore High School ou
pas ouais ouais c'est l'année prochaine
qu'il arrivait il va pas il va pas être
à de 10 mais il peut peut-être terminer
à deux cinq de six des ça dépend où ça
se trouve il terminera deux trois ce qui
est et si termine à deux trois faut
qu'il développe absolument le handle
parce qu'autrement il va pas beaucoup
être
utile quoi si c'est un gars qui plus ou
moins qu'il ait le ballon quand même
pour pour exister mais si il arrive pas
à développer le handle et là et la
vision le côté gestionnaire ça va être
un peu plus difficile mais je moi je je
raie pas le nom tout de suite parce que
le il y a quand même pas mal de choses
qui sont intéressantes et j'ai envie de
voir si le 3 points va arriver si le 3
pour un gestueux
sur un modèle queino Moby finalement
donc chaîne Stewart février 2005
effectivement le
la grosse cote de Manu celle d'Alan
c'est Azan Newell qui n'est que 34e au
composite 2024 né en octobre 2005 2 m 06
il jouait que 10 minutes par match
il fait un petit 10 sur 10 au lancer
franc lui aussi va être à la menthe
Verde académique comme Cooper flag
il a déjà des grosses offres pour la fac
Florida State Floride Alabama il vient
de Floride et il a un frère
qui est walkon à Georgia la fac de
chirurgien dis-moi Alan c'est un poste 4
un post-5 qu'est-ce que tu vois chez lui
qui est pareil bientôt fini physiquement
on imagine enfin en tout cas dans
peut-être mais
pas été trop calculée je pense qu'elle
est vraiment bonne
gaucher 10 sur 10 au lancer franc donc
le moi je l'ai regardé beaucoup tiré
parce que comme j'ai dit je jouais pas
beaucoup donc
j'achète le tir de A à Z en fait cocher
sur du sur du pick and pop de loin il
est à 25 à 3 points sur la complète et
encore grandir je pense qu'il peut faire
deux 10
je pense qu'il peut faire un petit peu
plus de 10 à être un post 4 5 gauchers
finisseur d'action protecteur de cercle
c'est pas parce qu'il a pas joué qu'il
est pas bon c'est que bon bah il y avait
il y avait une stew il y avait les
joueurs qui avaient un peu plus de
pedigree dans tout ça qui sont peut-être
meilleures que lui aujourd'hui mais
c'est un classement prospect moi je peux
pas mettre sa nouvelle trop bas parce
que je veux je veux vraiment le revoir
peut-être donc ça m'intéresse vraiment
de savoir comment ça va se passer à
Mondevert parce que il arrive avec
cooperfly et Vans qui est là qui est une
grosse grosse recrue un gros lycéen qui
sera Seigneur l'an prochain c'est pas
faire un front de court hyper hyper
intéressant à voir donc je sais pas quel
rôle il aura comment ils vont le
développer mais
je veux absolument le revoir j'aimerais
bien qu'il soit au 19 l'an prochain avec
timuricien Hongrie parce que je voudrais
voir dans ce qu'ils ont fait faire
Thomas est-ce que tu peux me dire qui tu
as dans ton deuxième groupe puisque là
on a parlé des joueurs de ton premier
groupe on a déjà parlé de certains de
ton deuxième groupe mais qui a tu as
d'autres dont on n'a pas parlé on n'a
pas parlé de Ron Hollande de Carter Nox
de Boogie fland de Jérémy fears et de de
David Castillo Dennis Evans Hollande et
dans mon deuxième groupe avec du coapit
du Newell Hollande qui était le plus
haut dans le groupe je continue avec toi
Alan qui tu as dans ton tiers 2 du
coupeur
flamme tout seul ensuite
j'ai renoland Jackson j'ai Boogie
Flandres alors il s'appelle johnuel mais
tout le monde l'appelle Boogie sur sur
place donc moi je l'appelle Boogie et et
les trois joueurs que j'ai un peu un peu
là avec carter Nox c'est un peu les
ailiers en gros les ailiers de l'équipe
et pour Guy Flandres qui est en 2006
donc je le mets là Boogie Flandres
effectivement il s'appelle johnuel donc
c'est rigolo déjà quand même
lui aussi vient du Bronx comme notre ami
Yann Jackson et archi Bishop stepina
kayeschool 13e au composite 2024
Griffin de mémoire je peux me tromper
2024 pour ceux qui nous écoutent ça veut
dire qu'ils rentreront en NCA en 2024
10 juillet 2006 donc un an de moins que
les autres postes 1 2 4 points s'y passe
décisifs de moyenne quand même 2,7
rebonds
non si c'est ça et non 3,6 passe
décisive de moyenne 4,6 points 4 sur 9 à
3 à 2 points et 7 sur 18 à 3 points 3
sur 4 seulement lancer franc sur toute
la compète donc Boogie flands
en fait je pense qu'il était il est
monté de moins bon et moins utile
aujourd'hui que fears et Castillo qui
était vraiment les leaders de l'équipe
d'ailleurs que Théo USA l'an dernier qui
était un peu l'âme de l'équipe mais
bougifland donc il y a un an de moins et
je pense que son poulet est assez
incroyable son poula pas trois points et
de très très hautes voltige que 7 sur 18
en prenant des poules il joue pas
beaucoup sur les derniers matchs donc on
a surtout vu nous on a eu la chance moi
j'ai la chance de le voir contre ma liée
Égypte où il a pas mal joué et
un bon instinct of ball pour défendre
des qualités de passe intéressante sur
pick and roll et un pull-up un jour quoi
je pense avec son physique du mal à
finir qui est pas très très bon
défensivement sur sur le porteur mais
voilà mais il a fait penser à bons
Island en fait quand je l'ai vu donc
c'est aussi la coupe de cheveux et tout
donc j'ai vraiment hâte de voir la suite
il a eu beaucoup d'offres c'est vrai que
les coach and sciais qu'il voulait
vraiment le voir et il a fini la compet
avec tes offres de des plus gros
programme donc vu qu'il est aussi très
jeune parce qu'il est juillet 2006
vraiment intéressant pour moi à suivre
Manu parle-moi de Renaud land donc qui
est quand même un de ce qui a le plus
gros pedigree il était déjà médaillé
d'or au U16 junior de l'année au lycée
il a déjà plein d'offres des grosses
facs il a joué 20 minutes de moyenne 59%
à deux points et 8 sur 19 à 3 points sur
la con en fait seulement 10 sur 17 au
lancer franc et voilà
ça donne ça donne un des leaders
offensifs de cette équipe
mettre 07 donc un des plus grands
joueurs de l'équipe aussi lui les
juillet 2005 donc là je normal pour pour
la compète on sait pas grand chose son
pedigree familial en tout cas moi je
sais pas grand chose il parle de sa
famille en disant qu'il vit joue pour
eux et qui veut on imagine donc un
milieu très très modeste il vient du
Texas oui c'est ça il est incroyable
une grosse grosse
tout le temps en train de s'amuser
toujours le sourire toujours en train de
danser ça a l'air d'être un sacré
personnage ok sympa voir comme anecdote
Manu qu'est-ce que tu peux me dire de
Ron Hollande
alors je tiens un profil moi je trouve
intéressant long fin mais qui est
capable de très bon en défense quand
tout est connecté qui est capable aussi
d'être un peu un peu fou fou si c'est
pas trop connecté comme on l'a pu le
voir sur le match contre l'Espagne ou
sur la dernière action ils se font un
peu prendre la [ __ ] par 7000 personnes
dans dans la salle parce qu'il a voulu
piquer la balle à un espagnol alors que
c'est fini c'est assez marrant à voir
autrement c'est un comme beaucoup
d'Américains très très actifs très très
actif toujours en action que ce soit en
attaque ou en défense moi j'ai aimé le
tir vraiment c'est assez c'est assez
polyvalent c'est notamment à trois
points mais il y a je trouve qu'il y a
quelque chose la gestuelle et a
peut-être un peu à revoir c'est ça avec
un son ballon est Paradise au niveau du
front donc c'est assez facilement
contrat s'il se retrouve face à des à
des joueurs
mon standing rich et une grande
envergure donc à avoir sur la finalité
mais c'est quelqu'un que j'ai vraiment
aimé voir donc j'ai intéressant aussi
dans la passe je trouve il a une bonne
moyenne à la place et il a un match
contre la Lituanie je crois ou les
Serbie je sais plus où il fait vraiment
un match intéressant à la passe donc il
y a quand même des flashs là dessus moi
je le vois plus comme un terme comme un
second porteur de balles quelque chose
comme ça
où il va être capable d'un peu tout
faire et si tous développent franchement
ça peut être super intéressant parce que
le 42% à 3 points laisse un peu rêveur
donc à avoir moi c'est un objet que j'ai
que j'ai aimé voir jouer en tout cas
surtout dans l'activité défensive ou
franchement il était vraiment partout
vraiment partout vocale franchement
super intéressant il est rapide moi je
l'avais vu au U16 et
effectivement
ces Américains ont passé pour moi
c'était le meilleur prospect de l'équipe
U16 l'an passé et il confirme en tout
cas il a encore progressé cette année
notamment sur le tir
anecdote que j'ai lu sur le site de USA
basketball il n'avait jamais vu la plage
avant ce championnat du monde Alan il
nous manque Carter Nox frère de Kevin
Floride il joue pour Tampa catholique
High School il jouait 16 minutes sur ce
FIBA U17 numéro 7 du composite ranking
2024 donc c'est pas mal il fait 1m96 il
est déjà bien tanqué 16 mai 2005
il a mis 10,5 points de moyenne avec une
très bonne réussite à deux points 25 sur
35 et assez mauvaise à 3 points 5 sur 20
9 sur 16 au lancer
franchement il a pas beaucoup joué il
était vraiment dans le rôle du backup de
Renault land
la seconde minute était limite plus
intéressante en termes de prospect parce
que sur la seconde 8 il y avait couper
flag il y avait Yann Jackson il y avait
Carter NOx et Bouygues et Nox il y a
surtout joué au football donc là c'est
vrai je pense c'est vraiment un joueur
qui mérite d'être vu dans un contexte
lycéen we Willy parce que là il était
vraiment
au football beaucoup de cut beaucoup de
dunk en transition beaucoup de catch and
shout à trois points
le geste est pas j'aime bien le geste là
aussi des pas incroyable 9 sur 16 volant
c'est pas pour un joueur de son âge
c'est moyen c'est pas c'est pas
incroyable mais c'est pas il y a un
définitif là-dessus donc c'était
vraiment il avait vraiment le rôle un
rôle tertiaire donc
rien pour son physique il mérite d'être
vu dans sa dernière Ana High School
parce que il a beaucoup d'offres donc
Kentucky bien entendu vient le frère je
pense que je pense que il reste à aller
là-bas mais il y avait beaucoup de
d'autres coachs qui ont parlé en bien et
qui disait que quand il était en rescool
il avait un rôle à assez différent et
qui est il montrait vraiment plus de
choses dans sa palette offensive donc à
revoir franchement au revoir avec
peut-être un tir à développer pour donc
comme pour Hollande d'ailleurs même s'il
a payé
[Musique]
Thomas
ultime
normalement je suis là yes tu es là
superbe
est-ce que tu peux me parler de David
Castillo dont on a pas parlé numéro 7
recrue espienne 2024
17 août 2005 c'était le shooter de cette
équipe Manu on a parlé 14 sur 40 à 3
points sur le tournoi et du coup il
était un peu indispensable pour le
spacing il a joué 21 minutes c'est un
des plus gros temps de jeu de timide
joue à barre il joue en High School dans
l'Oklahoma et il est team Griffin l'été
et lui aussi il était médaillé d'or en
U16 au FIBA américain l'année dernière
bon est-ce que c'est quelques quelqu'un
est-ce que c'est plus qu'un shooter
David Castillo est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose de plus un peu la question que je
me pose j'ai pas forcément l'impression
pour l'instant c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment un pur shooter shooter
référencé au niveau
ice school comme tu l'as dit au Haïti
white Biel donc team Griffin il jouait
que très Joh notre très gros prospect ça
s'artille vraiment dans tous les sens à
trois points ça prend des 10 15
tentatives par match donc c'est vraiment
un joueur qui prend quasiment la
totalité de ses shoots derrière l'art ça
prend assez peu de de shoot à deux
points donc il a un physique il est
quand même assez frais il fait 1m88 même
s'il a un bon premier pas ça genre assez
assez rapide quand même il a des
difficultés à finir au cercle pour
devenir plus qu'un un pur shooter va
falloir s'épaissir peut-être prendre en
taille vu que c'est ça n'est pas non
plus un fort passeur c'est pas un
gestionnaire c'est pas du tout un métier
qui fait jouer le jeu c'est vraiment
pure shooter donc dur d'exister en tant
que pur shutter quand tu fais que 1m88
faudrait qu'ils grandissent pour
vraiment être viable au plus haut niveau
je pense
David Castillo donc et le gestionnaire
de cette équipe
s'appelait Jeremy fears junior il vient
de rejoindre overtime Elite pour un an
avant d'aller théoriquement à Michigan
State puisque maintenant on peut faire
les deux on peut aller en prendre des
dollars et ensuite aller en NCA
recrut 42 un des recrues des recrues
lycéens les moins bien classés pourtant
un des leaders de cette équipe avec le
meilleur placement 20 minutes par match
10 points trois rebonds 4,4 passes
décisives 2,1 interception
51% à deux points seulement 8 types de
loin 3 sur 8 12 sur 16 au lancer il
vient de l'Illinois il ira donc à
Michigan stage je l'ai dit Alan
rapidinho qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce
qu'on se dit pour pour Jérémy Fierz il
va falloir qu'il grandisse il fait un
mètre 85 est-ce qu'il va grandir ou
est-ce que tu penses pas je crois qu'il
va grandir mais il est très fini je
pense que ça va être un super collège un
joueur de College je pense qu'il va être
avec Tom ISO en plus ça m'étonnerait pas
qu'il reste trois quatre ans à Michigan
State c'est pas
je peux pas le projeter je pense
aujourd'hui comme un wanandon quelque
chose comme ça parce qu'il est trop
petit il a pas non plus
pendant c'est un très fort défenseur sur
l'homme notamment sur le plan étoffatta
avec les plus les puissants pour sa
taille c'est vraiment physiquement c'est
vraiment quelque chose à voir donc
pas un prospect NBA pour moi aujourd'hui
mais vraiment un joueur
un futur super joueur de collecte qui va
défendre qui va passer avec le tir qui
va devoir s'améliorer bien sûr mais je
pense qu'il va pas trop grandir il est
déjà développé physiquement il est déjà
assez épais donc vraiment le genre de
joueur à avoir dans cette équipe U17 si
tu voulais gagner le tournoi en fait tu
pourras avoir que 12 prospects NBA il
faut aller 8 9 prospects et puis trois
joueurs dont on sait qui qui seront plus
d'écoles bleus ou des choses comme ça
même en une sieste donc le rôle qu'avait
devienne Harmon en fait il y a dans
l'équipe de 2010 de 2018 qui a été à
Oklahoma qui a été à Oregon après ce
genre de jour là
et il faut aussi un grand de 2 mètres 16
qui joue quasiment pas
Denis Evans qui est quand même hyper
bien classé dans la recrue lycéenne mais
et il a joué 35 minutes sur le tournoi
il a mis 7 contre c'est pas mal il avait
pris si j'avais vu avant le tournoi
parce que on prépare mes fiches il avait
pris il a pris 75 places dans le
classement Tony forcément je crois 4 7 3
4 mots donc c'est vraiment un Razer de
quelqu'un qui monte dernièrement quoi
ouais bah il a fait des triples doubles
avec les contre en fait
il crasse High School Riverside il a
fait un triple double avec 16 contre
notamment cette année donc voilà il
paraissait un peu à la traîne quand même
quand il était sur le terrain Manu il
est enfin voilà il rentrait dans le dans
le garbage time de toute façon Denis
il entrait quand les spectateurs le
scandait son nom
quand il restait une minute ouais il y
avait un côté on en avait parlé
d'ailleurs sur le groupe WhatsApp
mais je pense en fait il y a
il y a un truc c'est que c'est ça reste
mon avis mais je pense qu'en fait il
continue à s'habituer à son corps ça se
voit il arrive pas à bouger correctement
il est un peu consulter il est perdu
il sait pas ce qu'il fait en fait il
lève les bras il contre quoi sur un
terrain il fait que ça les rap des dunks
contre transition
donc le Mali où il doit jouer à la fin
peut-être deux ou trois minutes parce
qu'il y avait plus 47 il y avait que lui
qui avait pas marqué et du coup sur
trois ou quatre transitions consécutives
lui file la balle il arrive pas à
terminer au Cercle quoi
en fait je pense c'est plus une question
de motricité parce que autrement un mec
il est déjà quasiment à deux 15
c'est il a des bras immenses il doit
être à deux vins d'envergure
au niveau du corps en fait tu lui manque
juste du poids
mais sauf qu'il s'est passé son corps
quoi il sait pas courir c'est un peu un
David
monsieur Riou du Canada Olivier Rio du
Canada quoi c'est
ici les deux
c'est même pas si il peut faire des les
deux sont totalement
et puis pour traverser la raquette il
met deux heures quoi
de la motricités
nous là cette semaine il y a encore des
des mecs qui sont kiffe sur lui
notamment parce qu'il fait 15 pompes par
match quoi
c'est plus on s'approche des deux trente
ans
je l'ai pas mesuré mais c'est un
des longs bras et sur un long corps
généralement effectivement ça a cherché
Thomas vu qu'on a perdu pendant un
moment est-ce que tu as des tu as un
petit truc à dire soit sur
Stewart Noël Flandres
tout ce qui a été dit j'attends beaucoup
new age je suis vraiment d'accord avec
Alan je pense que c'est c'est le
meilleur joueur de ce que tu as cité
c'est vraiment un des plus gros talents
de cet effectif la taille qu'il a c'est
vraiment un très très fort shooter même
au niveau High School si il débloque un
bon niveau défensif dans le futur ça
pourrait vraiment être un très très fort
stretch fort voir five il prend pas mal
de un peu de taille et pas mal de poids
mais je pense ce sera plus un cas dans
le futur donc ça peut être un cas très
fort shooter et à débloquer la défense
encore bah écoutez on va voir en tout
cas mais c'est intéressant de de noter
son nom alors qu'il a il a peu joué
comme ça c'est aussi pour pour ça qu'on
fait ce genre de podcast
Thomas etre offline mais merci Thomas
pour pour ta première participation des
problèmes de son c'est normal c'est
bizutage chez envergure
Manu Alan vous allez voir du du U18 donc
on vous retrouvera peut-être plus tard
dans l'été ou peut-être à la rentrée
pour pour nous faire des bilans sur les
intern nationaux sur les Français tout
ça tout ça tout ça
voilà est-ce que est-ce que c'était bien
l'Espagne un highlight hors terrain à
retenir une anecdote
42 degrés dans la voiture entre les deux
salles et c'est vraiment très très très
chaud c'était mon avis au basket en live
donc ça ça a été on a fait on a vu
beaucoup c'était vraiment bien de
c'était la première fois qu'on faisait
des compètes or Europe et c'est vraiment
cool de voir
l'Australie l'Argentine ça c'était
vraiment le Mali c'était vraiment
vraiment le Canada un peu décevant
d'ailleurs si regarde un peu les bilans
qui vont sortir sur il y a pas
énormément sur des joueurs canadiens
c'est pas une génération incroyable mais
Timur essai Mali argentier Australie
c'était vraiment vraiment top réplique
dominicaine aussi réplique dominicaine
toujours toujours un ou deux joueurs
sympas en république Dominique surtout
les porteurs de balles qui qui débordent
l'école
l'école dominicaine du street Bull se
porte bien
voilà donc du show bah oui c'est pas
recommandé l'Andalousie l'été
effectivement c'est pas recommandé de
moins en moins merci les gars bisous à
tous et puis on se retrouve très bientôt
si vous voulez l'article écrit c'est
donc sur envergure.co et on vous dit on
vous répète abonnez-vous sur soit sur
Deezer Spotify Google pod Apple podcast
Google addict tout je ne sais pas
l'article 18 sur les Américains
il y a l'article des U20 qui va sortir
article U17 France qui est déjà sorti
voilà le podcast du 17 France aussi donc
voilà on est complet et vous pourrez
écouter ça même après l'été si vous
préférez ce sera toujours d'actualité
ciao tout le monde à bientôt